[Music]
and mixed nuts your first role was
playing a transvestite yeah in a scene
where you danced with Steve Martin it's
night kind of yeah I remember this scene
quite well and you towering over a Steve
mark it's a really funny scene and you
are very convincing in that role but it
was your first what's one of your first
big jobs wasn't it it was actually my
first film I had never I never I mean it
was Nora Ephron Fenn Nyquist was the DP
Rob Reiner Steve Martin Madeline Kahn
who I was obsessed with my whole life a
remarkable group of actors and I was
just I was blown away I mean up before
then I've been doing you know
Shakespeare in the Park for 300 bucks a
week and suddenly there's this
incredible spread of like pastry and
smoked fish it's amazing when you see a
movie I mean those of you who haven't
been on a movie set it really is a
remarkable waste of food yeah my first
day I thought there was gonna be a
read-through and I showed up in some in
some jeans and I had been practicing in
these six-inch stilettos because I was
playing a transvestite and I show up for
the first read-through or what I assumed
would be the first read-through and I'm
so nervous I'm literally shaking around
everybody because there's all these
movie stars and it freaks me out to see
them and the woman comes to the ad comes
down and says you know no you're you're
not gonna be in the read-through you're
gonna go upstairs and do a dance
rehearsal with Steve Steve Martin you
know Martin right yeah so I say no no no
no I can't because I don't have my shoes
and I'm wearing jeans and and what I was
really thinking in my in many ways she
said she said
it'll-it'll you'll get it she said but
we have some sweatpants for you once we
have some high heels for you I went with
[ __ ] they've got me yeah I went and I
changed and I realized that I had born
boxer shorts under my jeans and the guys
know when you wear boxer shorts with
sweatpants it's problematic you don't
get
you don't get a ton of protection
coverage or support and so I'm going to
meet Steve Martin for the first time was
a fairly curmudgeon II guy and we're
going to do the foxtrot and I don't know
if you know the foxtrot but the foxtrot
is accomplished by the man sticking his
leg between the woman's legs and leading
him around the dance floor and I thought
to myself I sort of chuckled to myself
boy would this be inappropriate if I you
know became around yes it it would be
inappropriate
absolutely if you became aroused and you
know how when you want to become aroused
it never works but then when this is a
totally inappro-- I would say it never
worked
[Applause]
I just for myself I 20% of the time
anyways that nothing could have been
more inappropriate so of course I get
probably the best I've ever had it was
Steve Martin the best and I'm I'm
mortified because we haven't even shook
hands yet and already and every time he
spins me it back into his head
[Applause]
and on
and I'm thinking to myself there's no
doubt I'm gonna get fired this is the
first movie and the last movie right all
right same day and Steve is just sort of
looking up at the ceiling
swinging me around and I want to say
I've come a long way since then all
right there's no reason to do that
there's no reason to go there I should
probably thank Steve if he's watching
because he didn't say anything we're not
saying anything yeah yeah he didn't want
to spoil I was literally I was like
going through the entire roster of the
New York Mets trying to make it stop but
it
you